allez on se fait dans le passé au
conseil de classe d'agathe etc et les
latéraux surprise combien de personnes
sur la photo de rentrée on fait zéro
émission à la photo de rentrer se plaît
mettez là je les remets shebab ont
enlevé on va le faire comme ça
combien de zéros initie man zéro
émission râler benayoun 3 oui moi aussi
la crise voilà il ya nicolas deuil et
mon poteau et il y à de l'acier en bas
côté là il a pas fait en tant que
chroniqueur yves dion on a cherché m'a
pas payé ça contient on parlerait
d'isabelle les champs on a créé par un
magnéto spécialement pour eux regardez
ils sont tous sur la photo de classe et
pourtant ils ont clairement redoublé
nicolas des zéro émission nous indique
qu'il est sur cette photo juste
lorsqu'il est pote avec le photographe
et qu'il avait besoin d'une nouvelle
photo pour son passeport christine lentz
zéro émission al reem à zéro émission
tout comme en boîte de nuit le jeune
rappeur nous a prouvé que si tu as des
claquettes tu rentres pas rachid arhab
12 émissions bien installé dans la bande
en début de saison l'ex membre du csa
n'aurait pas supporté son conseil de
classe
louis morin trois émissions étoile
montante de la télé mais étoile filante
de tpm p il est aujourd'hui chroniqueur
ponctuelles sur ses news or castaldi une
émission la célèbre directrice de
casting aurait décidé de ne plus
participer à tpm paix pour souffler deux
heures par jour sans supporter benjamin
yasmine go launcher glow va une émission
elle a décidé de prendre un peu de temps
pour essayer d'apprendre à épeler son
propre nom de famille christophe
carrière une émission le chroniqueur
historique de tpm paix a aujourd'hui
quitté l'émission pour se consacrer à
ses que de la télé mais surtout à ses
cheveux pierre ménès 20 émissions on le
retrouve aujourd'hui avec sa nouvelle
teinture dans le canal football club
caroline ithurbide neuf émissions on la
retrouve aujourd'hui dans ce n'est que
de la télé
emilie lopez 4 émissions elle est
aujourd'hui chroniqueuse dans ces que de
la télé et enfin guillaume genton après
trois chroniques et un applaudissement
il a finalement préféré se tourner vers
le passionnant métier de voix off
il officie aujourd'hui pour une émission
culturelle de ces 8
[Musique]
je voudrais leur dire on n'est pas
travail magnifique ce qui fait tout les
magnétos tuchbant potes
il est incroyable et dans tout ce que
j'ai vu il y en a qui vont peut-être
venir ils seront là cet été aussi avec
benjamin à partir de lundi qui sépare la
famille coup qui arriva
oui exactement pour le premier live de
la saison on a pu voir rita aura chanté
your songs chanter nation's oui la belle
chante et femmes d'état aura été là
c'était une chanteuse américaine va
aller toujours s'agiter doit toujours
américaine n'a pas changé la seule année
en séries tu auras et oui bien sûr ce
qu'elle 4 septembre et depuis joie
beaucoup d'artistes se sont succédé sur
la scène de tpe pme à prendre avait
larusso comme quoi rien mais alors
qu'est la route soient les plus connus
un arrêt alors on a fait une complice
dénouement
les
[Musique]
moi ce que tu veux
mais le mois à l'enfant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu sais
pas
j'te des 10 m
[Musique]
je crois que la chasse est raciste parce
qu'on les comptes ou d'argent de pierres
et de s'éclater
la querelle des
[Musique]
ce
ce soir
benoît
je vais quand même vous je ne fais que
voler aussi le meti faux bond
[Musique]
c
symbole
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est juste avant avant qu'on passe
à d'autres questions et qu'on fasse au
conseil de classe l'a gâtée qui est ce
que vous vous rappelez du moment le plus
gras sera qu'on en ait vécu dans cette
émission je pense même que ça presque
lancer la saison de la barca c'est sur
un live c'était michel les médias
étaient venus on le qui fait et voulait
pas lâcher la seule à moi mes frères
n'étaient pas en place
mais ce succès comme côté toraman mon
frère et tu sentes h ome de ouf à sortir
non mais sans déconner regardez ce
qu'est ou ses traders
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le président laisse prise dans les
salles dans la peau
[Musique]
alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
venez pas s'arrêter le garrot
l'embrasser
on a eu 2 et brassant j'en suis aussi
inquiète chance à un sosie de michael
moore n'a pas de raison d'état l'ont pas
dit qu'il s'était moi mais je ne savais
pas qu'il fallait une loi limite à tort
il est excellent et on va dire son nom
là et les non non pas du tout si hubert
seyrig berre voilà bon leurs bras et l'a
été
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
son défi
et je
[Applaudissements]
à quoi correspond le chiffre 342 c'est
le nombre de bafouillages de jean michel
maire au nombre d'invités cette saison
c'est le nombre de salles de sport qui
ont refusé mathieu non navires dont 342
habitants djamel christian clavier mike
tyson gay louis il était supprimé
magnéto sur un fil alors on les a tous
écouté sans merci les bonnes questions
franchement tu as peut-être tu tiens
tête un truc non franchement j'ai adoré
les magnétos de cette ville et j'étais
hyper content qu'il vienne il est
gratuitement les gars ou en allemagne et
tout va les pastilles magnéto alors
attachez vous à bien furios et ça fait
six ans qu'on ferme ma gueule
regardez on veut des meilleurs invités
de la saison on invitait préférez vous
le savez qu'elle est sans clavier est
avec moi pognon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais quand tu n'étais pas passé ouais
c'est karim
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si je peux résumer en un mot faire la
gueule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors d'accord quant à la balayette pour
gothard château de sa coupe de cheveux
brison p c'est surtout qu'on lit
toujours tu ne l'a dans le cul la mairie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une émission à s'accepter la chaîne il
me semble nrj 12 en tout cas qui
s'appelait oif
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
je crois que ça se passe bien en ciel
entre nous merci à tous en tout cas
devenue cette année
marleix s'est braqué une de mes invités
préféré sata des bois jolis bien sûr
l'oscillation oui c'est vrai je
m'habille et malick seck malik bentalha
c'est l'invité qui a vu le plus de fois
4 et laurent batlles il faudrait dire
paraître est génial et s'est demandé à
laurent baffie parce que je prends des
plots jerry demanda quel j ai aussi
j'aimerais bien kenji et j'aimerais ce
que vous aimeriez laurent baffie au
premier invité l'an pro sahraouis et
désire soir j'ai eu au téléphone tu dis
on démarre avec toi on voit une barre
car il a dit oui j'adore j'adore
stéphane plaza on vient de le voir mais
ça fait trois jours que vous êtes devant
chasseurs d'appart à will be no mercy
elle resta le béret golding et on adore
et cartes cadeaux parce qu'ils sont pas
la même heure ils sont plutôt que nous
donc forcément il ya moins de monde
devant la télé donc c'est un petit peu
voilà je vous le dis par un petit peu
biaisé il cartonne stéphane la phrase la
plus prononcée par moi même cette saison
sur la tête d'un chat iran c'est pas mon
délire où c'est d'accord pour nous un
bon délire ça n'est pas mon délire mais
à quelques mètres et mis la tête sous
l'eau c'est pas du tout mon délire et
vous avez vu stephen dunn fariboles
incroyable alors je vous dis la vérité
et c'est pas mon délire des baganda moi
c'est pas mon délire
et allez y perdre c'est pas mon délire
elle n'est pas mon délire j'ai trouvé
extrêmement jeunes ou les fans en délire
des bravos moi je trouve magnifique
franchement vous auriez pu être mon
délire s'il est malheureusement vous
n'êtes pas je vous le rappelle
amina n'a pas 10
[Applaudissements]